this report coming up does contain
discussions of suicide which some of you
may find distressing
that's the last photo of her and me
together which is significant because um
yeah
she loves surfing
in the months before Phoebe took her own
life her mum warned her University she
was struggling
Phoebe found lockdown isolating and then
her father was diagnosed with terminal
cancer but her mum says she was left in
the dark about how bad Phoebe got she
did have a um
suicide plan in October 2020 which was
six months
some months before she died and she told
the university about her
suicide plan
they didn't contact me
so I didn't know anything about anything
about that
in her last counseling session Phoebe
said she wanted the pain to stop but
denied feeling suicidal her mom says
though her words should have raised red
flags if they'd have phoned me
as they said they would I would have
been in that car to Newcastle and I
believe Phoebe would have would be here
today with me and so
I mean it's it's a it is a massive
brutal
trauma
Phoebe's University said in a statement
Phoebe's remembered fondly as a talented
and popular student in her 18 months
here our dedicated well-being team
provided her with ongoing support and
counseling the coroner in Phoebe's
inquest could not identify any point
where things could have been done
differently by the University or by her
private counselor
but Phoebe's mother and other parents
who've suffered a similar loss see
universities should have a legal duty of
care for students the same way they do
for their employees and they have
petitioned the parliament to change the
law the higher education Minister Robert
Halton said that he shared the bereaved
parents aims and that universities need
to prioritize mental health but he
stopped short of committing to any new
legislation
for Maxine Carrick that's not enough
she only found out after her son Oscar's
suicide that he had previously tried to
take his life but the consent to share
information that he gave weeks after
that wasn't applied retrospectively they
didn't have to tell us about the
suicide attempt they just have to tell
us about anything after that but they
could have told me that it was on P star
of their alert system which was the
highest of concern
in Oscar's case two the coroner rule the
University was not at fault Sheffield
Hallam said they take student health and
mental well-being extremely seriously
and were engaging on consent issues on a
sector-wide level
but for the parents who lost everything
was like these give little comfort
Sky News